NEWS POLL SHOWS GLEN DON YOUNGK
AHEAD.
LET ME SAY THIS SO YOU KNOW, I'M
NOT HERE TO ENDORSE ONE
CANDIDATE OVER ANOTHER.
THAT'S FOR VIRGINIA'S VOTERS TO
DECIDE.
WHAT I AM DOING HERE IS POINT
OUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS ONE YEAR
OUT FROM THE IMPORTANT 2022
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS DESPERATELY WANT
McAULIFFE TO WIN VIRGINIA AND
TONIGHT IS CAMPAIGN GETTING A
BIG BOOST FROM THE VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS.
>> NOW YOU-ALL KNOW THAT EVERY
FOUR YEARS WHEN THIS ELECTION
HAPPENS FOR GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA, IT'S A TIGHT ELECTION.
IT'S A CLOSE ELECTION.
AND IT IS A BELLWETHER FOR WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT HAPPENED IN VIRGINIA?
WELL, IN LARGE PART DETERMINE
WHAT HAPPENS IN 2022, 2024 AND
ON.
>> SO LET ME JUST POINT OUT THE
OBVIOUS HOVERING OVER THIS RACE
IS A SPECTOR OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND TERRY McAULIFFE
WHO WAS LEADING BUT HAS SLIPPED
IN THE POLLS IS TRYING TO C
CONVINCE VIRGINIA ZIRGVOTERS A
FOR GLENN YOUNGKIN IS A VOTE FOR
YOU KNOW WHO.
>> HE ENCOURAGED DONALD TRUMP
COULD BE REINSTATED TO OFFICE.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
>> WE DON'T NEED A LAP DOG FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> JUST A FEW DAYS AGO,
McAULIFFE CAMPAIGNED FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN THAT BEAT HIS
PREDECESSOR BY TEN POINTS IN
VIRGINIA BUT IN THE SAME STATE,
THIS RACE IS NECK AND NECK AND
BIDEN PUSHING YOUNGKIN INTO
TRUMP'S CORNER.
>> TERRY'S OPPONENT HAS MADE ALL
OF HIS PRIVATE PLEDGES OF
LOYALTY TO DONALD TRUMP AND WHAT
IS REALLY INTERESTING TO ME, HE
WON'T STAND NEXT TO DONALD TRUMP
NOW THAT THE CAMPAIGN IS ON.
THINK ABOUT IT.
HE WON'T ALLOW DONALD TRUMP TO
CAMPAIGN FOR HIM IN THIS STATE.
>> WELL, THE DEMOCRATS' STRATEGY
WORKED.
WILL IT WORK?
WE'LL FIND OUT SOON ENOUGH.
TUESDAY NIGHT TO BE SPECIFIC AND
WE'RE GOING TO COVER IT FOR
YOU-ALL NIGHT.
SO LIKE I SAID, McAULIFFE HAS
BEEN SLIPPING IN THE POLLS.
HE WANTED BIDEN'S INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SOCIAL SPENDING BILLS PASSED
BY NOW AND MAYBE MORE THAN THE
PRESIDENT DID.
HE PLEADED WITH DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS TO GET IT DONE.
IT'S CLOSE BUT IT'S NOT THERE
YET AND TOO LATE FOR McAULIFFE
WHERE VOTERS HAVE BEEN CASTING
BALLOTS FOR WEEKS NOW.
FOR HIS PART, YOUNGKIN IS TRYING
TO KEEP HIS DISTANCE FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND DIDN'T WANT
TO CAMPAIGN WITH HIM.
>> HE'S NOT COMING AND IN FACT,
WE'RE CAMPAIGNING AS VIRGINIANS
IN VIRGINIA WITH VIRGINIANS.
>> HIS STRATEGY HAS BEEN TO RILE
UP VOTERS WHAT KIDS ARE BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS AND THROWING
IN FEAR AND LIES ABOUT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY.
AGAIN, ON TUESDAY WE'LL KNOW HOW
VOTERS FEEL.
ONE THING IS FOR CERTAIN, ONE
THING IS SURE, IF YOUNGKIN WINS
TRUMP WILL TAKE CREDIT AND THE
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE LOST A STATE
PRESIDENT BIDEN WON BY TEN
POINTS JUST ONE YEAR AGO.
SO YES, THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE
IN THIS RACE.
REPERCUSSIONS NATIONWIDE AND
ELECTIONS TO COME.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING TODAY
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER OF
ILLINOIS IS RETIRING FROM
CONGRESS.
THAT IS TOO BAD BECAUSE
KINZINGER, A REPUBLICAN IS A
FIERCE CRITIC OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, ONE OF VERY FEW WHO
ARE WILLING TO STAND UP TO HIS
SLASH AND BURN STALE POLITICS
AND WHO STANDS UP FOR THE TRUTH
AND STANDS UP FOR OUR DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S A REAL SHAME.
KINZINGER IS ONE OF TEN
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE TO VOTE
TO IMPEACH THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND HE'S ONE OF THE ONLY TWO
REPUBLICANS WITH LIZ CHENEY TO
AGREE TO SIT ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE TO INVESTIGATE ON THE
DEADLY JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION
MAKING HIS ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY
AND SAYING THIS.
>> THIS COUNTRY IS IN AN
INCREDIBLY PERILOUS TIME BECAUSE
TO PREVAIL OR SURVIVE, YOU MUST
BELONG TO A TRIBE.
DEHUMANIZING EACH OTHER HAS
BECOME THE NORM.
WE'VE TAKEN IT FROM SOCIAL MEDIA
TO THE STREETS.
>> HE'S RIGHT.
DEHUMANIZING BEHAVIOR HAS BECOME
THE NORM.
I'LL GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES.
SO BEAR WITH ME.
FOLLOWERS OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT FED A CONSTANT STREAM
OF LIES THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
THOUGHT IT WAS OKAY TO STORM THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
DEHUMANIZING BEHAVIOR.
FIVE PEOPLE DIED THAT YET.
YET, SOME OF KINZINGER'S GOP'S
OUT RIGHT DISMISSING THE
VIOLENCE.
>> THERE WAS NO INSURE RRECTIOND
TO CALL IT AN INSURE
RECOLLECTION IN MY OPINION IS A
BOLDFACE LIE.
>> OUT RIGHT PROPAGANDA AND LIES
BEING USED AGAINST LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS ESPECIALLY TRUMP
VOTERS.
AS A RESULT, THE DOJ IS
HARASSING PEACEFUL PATRIOTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> IT WAS TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES THAT DAY, NOT
TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO WERE TAKING
THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
>> WHEN I SEE THIS SHEET ON OUR
TIMELINE AND ON THE, LET'S SEE,
OKAY, AT 2:07 A MOB OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS BREACHED THE STEPS.
I DON'T KNOW WHO DID A POLL THAT
IS TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN THINGS WORSE
THAN PEOPLE WITHOUT ANY FIREARMS
COMING INTO A BUILDING.
>> ADAM KINZINGER CALLING OUT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WITHOUT
SAYING HIS NAME.
>> WE HAVE ALLOWED LEADERS TO
REACH POWER SELLING THE FALSE
PREMISE THAT STRENGTH COMES FROM
DEHUMANIZING THOSE WHO LOOK, ACT
OR THINK DIFFERENTLY THAN WE DO.
>> ALSO APPLIES TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS RATHER THAN DEBATING
ISSUES ON THE FLOOR OF THE
HOUSE, WHICH IS THEIR JOB,
SCREAM AT THEIR OPPONENTS ON THE
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
>> A BABY UP UNTIL BIRTH IS LACK
OF CIVILITY.
CALLED MURDER.
HOW ABOUT THE BORDER DOWN THERE?
LACK OF CIVILITY.
LACK OF LAWS.
>> THE BASIC THING YOU'RE TAUGHT
IN CHURCH, RESPECT --
>> GOP REPRESENTATIVE MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE'S EGREGIOUS
BEHAVIOR IS EMBARRASSING, A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS YELLING AT A
COLLEAGUE IN PUBLIC BUT SADLY,
NOT UNUSUAL ANYMORE ACCORDING TO
ADAM KINZINGER.
>> IN CONGRESS, I'VE WITNESSED
HOW DIVISION IS HEAVILY ROOTED.
THERE IS LITTLE TO NO DESIRE TO
BRIDGE OUR DIFFERENCES AND UNITY
IS NO LONGER A WORD WE USE.
>> SO, WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE?
WHERE WE GO IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
AND WHEN TRUTH TELLING DEMOCRACY
DEFENDING REPUBLICANS DON'T
THINK THERE IS A PLACE FOR THEM
IN THE PARTY ANYMORE, IT'S TIME
FOR THE GOP TO DO REAL SOUL